Deliver sitting at the table sitting at the
bar in front of me I'm saying like God damn
lady
That's pretty competitive as fuck previous
fuckI want to listen.
Okay
Fuck youIt's crazy that. You can but it
can't really hear me.
I feel like I made enough money yesterday
And they work the shit out of me at you they
both places bro they work the shit out of me
Ain't nobody coming to meI'm thinking of my
head like that because you do it wrong.
I asked as soon as I get there you want to
start a fan you want to start a fan you want
to start a Time
And then I'm fucking with them again when
they first interaction I'm leaving less I'm
I'm not talking about real life shit we
didn't say that again
Back I'm just trying to be came and enjoyed
itself
A fucking bartender
Not the whole time maybe don't have time
But not during the game
The most need to be coming out and even
faster if we losing me and remember we win
Some might notBut it's okay.
Because they got but I don't see them about
30,000 times
If I'm not seeing you I'm seeing you soon
when I see you soon
Like he's like he told me I didn't even
realize she's my regular that's my baby all
the time
Hey Nicole
Oh my God I got them out on my Sims game